hello welcome to this video and
fortunately I have no video of me
crossing the 2400 mark again because I
want a very quick game by disconnection
of the opponent um yeah but I'm glad to
be back on a on a decent rating I'm
still not playing on that level it still
kind of kind of rusty or how you may
want to call it but at least the points
are back so we had a system modern banco
in a way black not taking on a six early
on but doing it in this delayed fashion
yeah but hey this is where my theory
ends and it it looks good for what yeah
what's the what's the deal about all
this okay let me let me just develop and
try to play along normal bank or lines
I wondered if he had a form didn't go
for it one definite upside of this
opening is that you can play many
somewhat standard moves and even if they
are not quite the best they are still
kind of playable
ok this one I don't know do I want to
place you for not don't really like this
idea so much I think I rather take and
go and I'd be five yeah that should be
quite decent pressure this should be
really okay my point by the way is
international us at all bets I didn't
really look at it could could have been
Magnus garden for Oliver I didn't really
checked okay so he's not trading the
Queen going to e3 instead okay so queen
bee three try to trade Queens again is
that an option it will win if you place
bishops III it wins the porn bag
probably equal probably about equal no
that's okay
oh no he removes the Queen yeah maybe
try and force some attack IAM should f
62 looks kind of normal
yeah yes play there of course against
the king how to do that Jim Queen to see
295 something that I think it's kind of
irritating okay have night f8 I won't
ever should go Quincy to wire this is
just okay let's stay active here I 25
Bishop f95 9 f8 shouldn't be all that
dangerous
yeah I'm sure what you should do I mean
I just want to take on be to this one
yeah okay I can go back to g7 or just
grab me too I mean okay why not why can
I not just grab me too I'm also
threatening on f2 so he has to take
basically yeah now I can take with the
Queen or with the night it's about
possible 90s 5v5 yeah I mean I tix looks
like it basically wins the a pawn don't
see how it covers it yeah that was kind
of plea I am he needs some counterplay
night and he takes it knight c6 this
this could be an idea it takes with the
rook okay how to do this now rookie 7i
have 95
maybe this one check I a screw key one
that's stupid I was thinking he has to
move the king and then I want to acquit
be eight but of course that's not really
the case okay i hope i didn't spoil my
chance to see it too much
okay yes I like I think the night is
stable now on d5 hunt I have chances to
start chances to win da porn so let's
see he has to take basically or is there
something else time morning um yeah so I
want to pawn can I win so thing check
check check check
so you're surprised that you allow to go
into a key and poor and name check check
check white resilience come on tough
game yeah banku strikes again I don't
know I think you're quite okay then i
made some some weird decisions all this
is looking somewhat standard ok and now
not be five i think makes sense yeah if
he trades now i think i'm in good shape
here this i would probably get this back
the engine gives before that's
interesting because I probably have
issues with taking yes yeah it's a very
nice idea by the comp if I check going
to this yeah so probably he should do
this however I mean I'm not sure that he
threatening all that much the engine
wants to go back and claims this is
roughly equal possible this is this and
still there are things hanging yeah ok
so now he tried to get this attack but
ok the engine just wants to take on b2
which felt a little bit too too weird to
me but ok this is also fine up to this
point it's pretty much engine play
and now rook takes the simplest the best
yeah yeah okay I overlooked one idea i
overlooked this one check that I have my
own attack here yeah I'm winning now I
didn't see that idea actually I I
completely forgot about who he won I was
thinking I get this in and then i have
this pin and the things not a bad idea
in itself but he has rookie one and now
I've spoiled a bit of my advantage okay
the computer wants to go see form and
here it only gives me a slight edge but
I think this is kind of nice the apron
is more of a weakness and strength the
way it turned out and wanted very
quickly which wasn't probably all that
necessary yeah and here on four against
three with Knights has good winning
chances it's not a clean win per se but
you have very good chances to win okay
well thanks for watching